welcome back to New Rockstars it's me
Tommy B and today we're whipping up a
batch of Star Wars awesomeness as always
a bad boy breaking down bad batch beats
me anyway we're gonna catch up on
episodes four through eight today once
again I'm only doing key moments and
some Easter eggs from these episodes
I'll be back next week and give episode
9 the full breakdown treatment it
deserves baby let's get into it episode
4 is titled simply faster and it brings
us to the bad batch into the high-speed
world of speeder racing now if pod
racing is NASCAR as I believe Ryan Airy
pointed out Speed Racer is definitely
formula one they're sleeker they're
thinner the cars are going fast I don't
understand how one crashes and you don't
die although more on maybe that later
wrecker Tech and Omega travel was said
to the planet zaffadoon in a world where
they're a ton of alien species myself to
the naked eye I spotted quilex aqualish
rhodiums and more oh my Sid's got a hell
of a racer in Teo a Droid voiced by John
ralphio himself Ben Schwartz quartz was
also one of the vocal contributors to
bb-8 in the Force awakens along with
Bill Hader unfortunately Teo loses to
mobster greeny milegi's racer jet Venom
Greenie Milady is voiced By Ernie Hudson
who hopefully you know from Ghostbusters
and not from Oz this causes Sid to
become property of greeny malagi unless
the bad batch can win her back in a
double or nothing rematch Teo has been
freshly rebuilt and reinvigorated he's a
Droid who races on instincts it's the
opposite of what you think and then he
steps right in front of a car and gets
destroyed so Tech has to race and he
wins a tough battle against a bunch of
droids and Jet Venom we see a protocol
Droid a BX commando droid and a battle
droid with really cool face paint
there's also a Biff watching the race
and probably leaving his Cantina band
mates without a clarinet player so no
jizz music that day I guess the bad
batch gets sent back and a warning from
greedy milegi not to trust her I'm sure
that won't come back later anyway Honda
episode 5. now we gotta go back way back
back at the Time episode 5 in Tomb deals
with an ancient artifact and those that
liberate them one of those such people
is fee and she's back in this app
episode Omega and wrecker are looking
for spare ship parts like compressors in
a junkyard when Omega comes across
something fee later identifies as a
compass the compass leads him to the Cal
Dairy trinary system a bleak desolate
planet and a couple of Bleak desolate
moons what a package Tekken record look
at some ancient etchings and think they
might be one thousand year old Jedi
script to which fee says think older
what's older than the Jedi we have the
Father the brother and the sister there
were ancient beings that symbolize the
force that we all know the force users
were the band do who we saw in Star Wars
Rebels that refer to themselves as
people in the middle the middle on ABC
great show look it up IMDb the bad backs
you have to solve a bunch of puzzles
that gave me flashbacks to spending
hours and hours trying to move stones
and levers and Jedi Fallen order until I
finally just begged my nephews better at
gaming to do it for me feeding the gang
find the treasure the heart of the
mountain and Scar and all once they
remove the treasure all hell breaks
loose this giant Mech Jagger thing that
shoots concentrated energy all a death
star the Starkiller base comes up from
the earth is defeated by returning the
heart of the mountain to to its place
how Indiana Jones of you Dave filoni wow
the Lucas family they really are
incestuous taking care of yourself is
important but we're not all Geniuses and
Poets some of us review the bad batch
for a living it's a good thing geology
makes it easy to do huh look at this
geology is a 16-time award-winning
personalized skin care company
recognized in hypebeast birdie Men's
Health Esquire and ask men grooming
Awards and boasts over 6 000 five-star
reviews just take a 30 second diagnostic
quiz in geology will create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
customized just for you with ingredients
that our dermatologist tested proven to
work and personalized to your needs for
Hair Care geology's got strengthening
shampoo and conditioner and co-wash
which will transform your routine and
deliver the best hairier life it extends
the time between washes and replaces the
need for so many products so you wash
your hair less and you save money more
that's method even I understand they
also offer body washes and deodoro
veterans that are free of harsh
ingredients and smell
great for skin care they have you
covered from all angles fight acne
reduce oiliness prevent wrinkles combat
darker puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
their daily personalized skin care
routine comes with two face washes
morning face cream retinol night cream
and eye cream that's 24 hours of creams
baby and right now for a limited time
you get your five piece trial set for
only 15 if you use the code Rockstar 70
at checkout that's our 150 dollars a
product for just 15 bucks and on top of
that you'll get an additional bonus
offer on one of their brand new skin
hair and body products of your choice
when you add it to your trial to get
started just click the link in the
description let's make those faces
beautiful baby try there's an awesome
episode maybe buy favorite because it
features a Jedi Wookie gungy my man
please let me be your fully felony fully
artist unfortunately Genji is being
Wookie traffic by the Vanguard axis this
is a gang of Droids that seem to
exclusively deal in dangerous and
illegal Goods we see a huge cargo bay
that is reminiscent of the one on Star
Destroyers Tech has created the
forgeries to fool the empire for
Vanguard one reason I think will come in
hand in a later episode Omega is
supposed to be guarding the ship but a
bad feeling leads her to investigate
causing her to discover gungy one of
ahsoka's top trainees we've seen him on
the Clone Wars now he's here on the bad
batch good for you gunji the BB manages
to liberate gunji from the Vanguard axis
oh thank Genji goodness as the Survivor
of the Jedi Purge Reggie is very
distrustful of the bad batch and only
eats after Omega assures him it's safe
and as Hunter says when it came to order
66 we didn't follow those orders the bad
batch in gunji head to kashyyk the
Wookie Planet seen most notably in the
Star Wars holiday special I'm kidding
unfortunately the Empire is also there
and they destroyed the village the bad
batch had planned to drop gungy off the
gang encounters the kinra web but
fortunately gungy defuses the situation
those Wookies are so handy the way they
can speak to animals it's really
beautiful back at the smoldering Village
the bad batch and seas Trend oceans
marching with a Wookie hostage they
destroy some Wookie etchings which
really pisses off gunji so he starts
murking transotions really enjoyable to
watch for me there's also Imperial tanks
rolling in so this should be a party The
Wookie Cavalry arrives and they rescue
the bad batch in gunji and they all get
brought back to their Wookiee Village an
elder Wookie agrees to take Genji in but
everyone is in danger as the Troopers
discover lightsaber markings on the
battle tanks now the Hunt is on for our
little furry Jedi gungy is nearly killed
by a Trans Ocean before a group of
kinraths coming to save them those
little spider creatures back to the
rescue and by little I mean huge and
scary Dungey is going to stay with the
wookies and the bad batches on to their
next adventure which is episode 7 the
Clone conspiracy it takes us back to
Coruscant and the Clone Trooper bar that
is 79s what I wouldn't give to have a
Miller High Life at 79s we first saw 79s
in the Clone Wars animated series
episode called orders in the bad patch
it's still functioning as a hangout for
clones to relax blow off steam and
lament about the guilt of destroying
their Homeworld of kamino under Admiral
rampart's orders which is exactly what
we find clone troopers slip and K doing
before they are clearly overheard by
some Rampart Loyalists and attack Tate
is killed but slip escapes and goes into
Hindi I found it interesting that
there's a clone trooper named slip as
there's also a constricted Trooper named
slip in the force awakens Trooper FN
2003 I mean this is obviously a
coincidence but maybe this was a tribute
to that Trooper who slipped and fell and
died very early on pushing Finn to
abandon the Stormtrooper Army and join
the resistance in the Senate ramparts
plan for a volunteer army is gaining
traction until Balor Ghana in Rio chuchi
the young pantoran Senator we first met
in the Clone Wars they pushed back and
they say the Empire must first take care
of the clone troopers before bringing on
a new Army this is actually well
received by the rest of the Senate much
to rampart's frustration Rampart learns
that Senator chuchi is looking for slip
so she can get the whole story on what
actually happened on Camino the order is
a mysterious Bounty Hunter to take out
slip instead of their chuchi Organa then
sends r2c C4 welcome back to get chuchi
and they secretly meet and decide to
take down Rampart slip requests the
rescue over his comps but instead
Senator chucci finds him first they're
quickly ambushed by the Bounty Hunter
and slip is killed along with Tucci's
guards it looks like Tucci herself is
toast one of mysterious figures stuns
the Bounty Hunter that figure my friends
is Captain Rex welcome back my man he
and chuchi remove the Bounty Hunter's
mask and it's a clone clone assassins
what's going on I need to do a little
deeper digging on that the Clone
assassin doesn't offer much help but
we're offing himself leaving Senator
Tucci with more questions than answers
answers will hopefully find in episode 8
episode 8 sends the bad batch to
Coruscant after receiving a message from
Captain Rex asking them to retrieve
backup footage proving Admiral Rampart
attacked kamino the boys are elected to
take the mission as going back to
Coruscant risks exposing the truth if
they're alive but Rex compels them to
help their clone Brothers get Justice
once there the bad batch meets with Rex
and Senator chuchi and hatches a plan to
steal the footage from the venator which
is a type of star destroyer which
conveniently happens to be being in a
shipyard on Coruscant chucci takes Omega
with her to meet Cambodian Senator
batoni batoni is reluctant to testify
because she feels like her people are
either gone or scattered throughout the
Galaxy but agrees to finally testify if
the bad batch can find that footage
proving rampart's involvement the bad
batch that hitch a ride to the veteran
by hijacking a Droid operated transport
they break in and upload the footage we
use Wreckers brood strength to soap and
a hatch then they get attacked by clone
troopers again the bad batch always
using the stun function because they
don't want to kill their brothers even
when their brothers are trying to kill
them and then my favorite moment of the
episode wrecker figures out that they
can slingshot them out of the Escape pod
and go over all of the clone troopers
and into safety I mean this to me Star
Wars is famous for using their escape
pods in the very first opening moments
of A New Hope R2D2 and C3PO are forced
to escape in an escape pod and again
earlier in this season we saw Echo Tech
and Omega escaping one of those cargo
Pods at the end of the first episode of
the whole season so two very cool
moments in Escape pods already in this
season I like it give me more Escape
pods I'm an escape pod guy so they meet
up with Omega Omega gives the footage to
Baylor Ghana and then it's shown to the
Senate Ram Partners arrested in the
emperor Rises up to make a shocking
appearance that he hasn't been seen in a
long time this is where the emperor
brilliantly uses 40 chests like he
always does and he points to the clones
being willing to destroy Camino as
evidence for the need of a volunteer
army he's planting the seeds of distrust
in the Clones even though that's exactly
what Rampart wanted to do Rampart ends
up being a sacrificial lamb and the
emperor's plan to get his own volunteer
army now the episode ends with Echo
deciding to go with Captain Rex to help
former Clone Troopers that need his help
that's all from me next week we'll be
breaking down episode 9 and each week
after that we will also have a dedicated
video for individual episodes follow me
and Tommy bech told follow new rap stars
on all platforms don't forget to like
And subscribe check out our awesome
merch at nerdriot.com and for now I have
spoken
[Music]
foreign